GOAL FOR THE DALLAS STARS. ARCA.
BEHIND HIS OWN NET TO GETO THE .
THE KINGS WILL HAVE ANOTHERQUIC.
BACK FOR KOPITAR.
LOOKING TO RECEIVE
KALIYEV MOVING IN.
BANK PASSED FOR BY TYLER
SEGUIN, ONTO THECH IN OF THE
KINGS HAVE A 7-0
ADVANTAGE IN SHOTS ON GOAL READ
G
THE YEAR.
ALSO SOME QUESTIONS GOING
FORWARD ABOUT WHICH GOALTENDER
TH ON THE PLAY.
BUT THE KINGS CONTINUED TO HAVE
GOOD
CORRECTLY.
>> Alex: EDLER HOLDING ON,
BROWN AND FRIEND TO REDIRECT
THAT OFFICE
DOUGHTY BANKSICELY DONE TO TIP T
OUT OF THE ZONE.
SHOT SWALLOWED
UP BY OETTINGER FOR A WHISTLE.
THE MAN OF THE HOUR GETTING INTO
>> Snoop Dogg: I SHOT.
WATCH OUT.UILD A HOCKEY PLAYER W
YOU WANT HIM TO PLAY, CHECK,
CHECK, CHECK, CHECK, THE LIST IS
ICING.
DANAULT FLIPS IT INTO THE DALLAL
FRIEND, TALKING BEFORE THE GAME,
SET, GOTBY QUICK.
>> Jim: THAT WASANOV AGAIN ON T.
ROLLING SEASON, HAS HAD THREEUN.
DURZI, WHO HAD THE STICK,  SMAR.
GET IT PASS, KEMPE
SUTER CARRIES IT OVER THE BE.
NOW JONATHAN QUICK IS THE MAIN
NAVIGATES THE TRAFFIC.HOME PLAY,
DOESN'T CONNECT.
AND THE STARS GET
VIRTUALLY NO CHANCES
SEGUIN.
MIKEY ANDERSON.
PUCK ROLLS TO THE FAR
1:19 TO GO O THE LIGHTNING -- TS
THIS ONE FROM ATHANASIOU.